bonjour france belvaux viager merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france alors c'est la fin
des et terrasse éphémère est ce que tous
les restaurateurs ont enlevé leurs
terrasses des trottoirs
déjà je voudrais rectifier quelque chose
c'est pas des traces éphémères mais ce
sont des terrasses estivales c'était au
départ des terrasse éphémère qui sont
besoin de suite a noté gociations avec
la mairie de paris avec la ville de
paris des terrasses estivales
et on peut dire
c'est la fon est terrassé festival et ça
a été un réel succès ces terrasses
estivales puisqu'on a eu douze mille
terrasses estivales sur la ville de
paris est-ce que ça à compenser le
manque à gagner du confinement
alors ça pas compenser complètement
parce que comme vous le savez il ya on a
eu un manque de touristes à paris pour
la deuxième année consécutive c'est de
nouveau la région où il ya le moins de
touristes mais évidemment ça a sauvé la
saison de nombreux restaurateurs je vais
vous donner deux chiffres qui vous allez
tout de suite comprendre avant de les
terrasses estivales il y avait à paris
environ 5500 terrasse avec les terrasses
estivales nous a permis d'avoir douze
mille terrasse estivale donc de nombreux
restaurants qu'il y avait trois quatre
tables en terrasse parce que la leur
situation géographique s'y prêtait pas
se sont retrouvés avec 25 30 places sur
les places de stationnement donc c'est
tout autre chose comme on le voit dans
votre reportage les clients étaient très
contents et est ce que finalement on
aurait pu pérenniser cette mesure même
même cet hiver 2 ses terrasses est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous
demandez
de choses on demande pas puisque c'était
l'accord était très précise c'est à dire
les terrasses estivales c'est du 1er
avril au 31 octobre donc ça c'est très
clair après il y a une possibilité je
peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus
de 1500 demandes de pérennisation de ces
terrasses sur les places de
stationnement à partir du moment où la
terrasse et une place de stationnement
et non pas sur une place de livraison et
et donc vous avez bon espoir d'obtenir
ces autorisations pour pour le mois
d'avril prochain
et ce sera payante pas parce que c'est
là la question aussi un alors nous nous
avions réussi à obtenir la gratuité de
ces états à partir du mans on occupe
l'espace public oui ce sera payant à
partir d'avril prochain mais
ccg lire pour les restaurateurs
c'est toujours intéressant quand même
d'avoir s'était rassis alors des
terrasses qui sont très agréables
effectivement à la fois pour vous pour
vos affaires pour les clients mais pas
toujours eu pour les riverains ça a pesé
aussi cela dans la décision
ah oui effectivement il ya de nombreux
l'association de riverains qui se sont
montés et qui se plaignent des terrasses
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que la
plupart des restaurateurs des cafés et
respecte après ceux qui ne respectent
pas je rappelle quand même le règlement
des terrasses estivales c'est pas de
musique et fermeture à 22 heures
certains respectent pas c'est vrai bien
cela faut les sanctionner et nous on au
syndicat umih comme le com de collègues
génie on n'ira pas les défendre c'est le
règlement est clair c'est pas de pas de
chauffage pas de toi ça ne peut être
qu'un parasols pas de lumière et
fermeture à 22h jusque je veux dire la
wii un certain nombre ne respecte pas et
bien cela faut les sanctionner alors que
penser aussi aux anges et moi si je me
trompe mais certains restaurateurs n'ont
pas de démonter leurs terrasses pourquoi
écouter les forêts où il faut les voir
au cas par cas alors si on parle de ceux
qui n'ont pas démonté parce qu'ils sont
sur des places de stationnement et ont
fait une demande de pérennisation de
leur terrasse là c'est possible les
autres sont dans l'illégalité ils vont
avoir une amende et la ville de paris
viendra démonter leurs terrasses alors
serait-ce donc ça veut dire qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui et les clients vont devoir
déjeuner ou dîner à l'intérieur des
restaurants est ce que vous craignez à
une désertion avec la lame la
progression des contaminations du virus
attention terrasse terrasse estivale ne
veut pas dire qu'on a fermé des
terrasses historique puisque
voilà alors ceux qui n'ont pas de
terrasse et bien effectivement les
clients devons être à l'intérieur et je
vous rappelle que nous avons toujours
puisque nous sommes quand même la
profession la plus stigmatisée depuis sa
crise qu vide il rappelle que nous avons
toujours le pass sanitaire donc chez
nous pour entrer dans un établissement
il faut montrer on peut dire pas de
blanche il faut avoir un passé de terre
alors justement à propos de cette
question de ne pas sanitaire comment est
ce que vous vous perceviez cette
obligation d'avoir son son passe
lorsqu'on était sur une une terrasse
éphémère d'autres pays comme la belgique
n'ont pas adopté cette cette mesure là
est-ce que c'était contraignant
depuis le début on était contre ce pas
sanitairement en terrasse parce que je
lui à paris vous prenez le métro on vous
demande pas le pas salutaire vous prenez
le train alors normalement vous de voir
le pass and i ter moi je peux vous dire
pour prendre le train régulièrement que
ce n'est pas tout le temps qu'on me
demande de montrer le pass sanitaires
par contre le passage était à
l'intérieur des établissements oui
maintenant c'est devenu une habitude nos
clients savent ils présentent leur passé
iter et je rappelle que notre personnel
est également a également un pass
sanitaire est ce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
contrôler beaucoup de verbalisation tu
assures se passe à lithaire alors oui
oui il ya eu il ya eu des ja du qu'il ya
eu des contrôles il continue y avoir des
contrôles
verbalisation pas tant que ça parce que
la profession s'est mis au diapason et
puis on a tous mis en place ce fameux
pas sanitaires merci beaucoup franglais
de vaud d'avoir répondu à la question ce
matin sur rtl france